was the one flying the plane that killed
all of his CV in aviation is exceptional
as a pilot is probably up at least in
the top 10 percent of aviators we know
how the Shoreham disaster happened but
despite an investigation and a lengthy
court case we may never know for sure
why it happened there was nothing wrong
with the plane the weather was perfect
the pilot was experienced but for some
reason
Andy Hills Hawker hunter jets swooped
above a busy dual carriageway and failed
to pull up in time 11 men died in the
crash Andy hill seen here on the left
had begun his career in the Royal Air
Force before becoming a commercial
passenger pilot with British Airways as
a hobby
he flew vintage aircraft at displays
what's he gonna do at the top this was
him performing aerobatics in the same
Hawker hunter jet a few weeks prior to
the disaster the display in Ireland
passed off with that incident fellow
pilot Oliver Wheeldon who owns a jet
once flown by the red arrows had worked
with him he's a consummate professional
he's he's a chap that if you look at his
history and background he is he
epitomizes being at the top of his game
I don't think anybody would question
that and he has the most extraordinary
records he really is a very talented
hugely intelligent intelligence and
bright guy his accomplishments are
pretty significant as a pilot he's
probably up at least in the top 10% of
aviators through his generation of
training in the Royal Air Force but
something went catastrophic ly wrong
when he flew at the Shoreham airshow on
August 22nd 2015
[Music]
he was attempting what he called a bent
loop but the jet wasn't going fast
enough or high enough to complete the
inverted circle he should have been able
to abort the manoeuvre safely but
instead the plane carried on heading
towards the ground with inevitable
consequences crashed in the busy 8:27
the fireball engulfing cars and people
who'd gathered them to watch the display
among those killed was footballer Jacob
shilts he and a team mates were on their
way to a match
it hit the players very hard very hard
and effectively destroyed the were the
United team I think they just couldn't
bear to play them anymore for three and
a half years his parents have struggled
to understand why the crash happened
question arises our fast jets suitable
aircraft to be doing air displays like
that now they weren't designed for
looping the loop they were designed for
a air defense they were fight it fight
it fight oh bombers won't think you know
this wasn't wasn't there their design
well okay I suppose it might be an
entertainment to watch a juggernaut
doing doing handbrake turns I don't know
but you know it just just seemed a bit
bizarre
really
despite the carnage on the grounds Andy
Hill was thrown clear of the plane and
survived though with serious injuries
an accident investigation found no
mechanical malfunction and three months
after the crash he was interviewed by
police and eventually the decision was
taken to prosecute he said he had no
memory of the crash but his explanation
was essentially that the loop was so
badly executed that he must have been
disorientated possibly due to
gravitational pressure or a lack of
oxygen jet pilots are accustomed to
experiencing g-forces during
acceleration at altitude and they should
know how to deal with it Mark Petrie
flies another vintage military aircraft
like the hunter it was developed in the
1950s and he regularly encounters
g-force when performing aerobatics at
air shows instead of me weighing one I
now weigh four times what I did before
and especially when I'm wearing a helmet
that weighs two and a half kilos
multiply that by four that's on your
neck and you've got a still bell to move
your head around with that increased
weight on your head
in extremes such pressure can lead to a
blackout blackout doesn't actually
necessarily mean you have completely
passed out what it does mean is you've
lost all your sensory perception gray
out is where you start to lose the
eyesight first the issue comes if you do
a rapid onset of G and you weren't
prepared
you may go straight through grayer into
black out into G lot and then you have
issues a bit like with the red arrows
gonna form us a few years ago in 2011 a
member of the RAF display team was
killed when his Hawk jet crashed an
inquest concluded that John egging had
probably fallen unconscious during the
flight unlike Shoreham no one else was
killed or injured a cockpit camera
suggested Andy Hill was conscious during
his routine but his defense successfully
argued he must have been cognitively
impaired it would explain certainly the
unusual part of the maneuver over the
top and the lack of response until the
airplane was pointing 90 degrees down
had Andy's been fully conscious and
aware I would have expected he would
have spotted that the height at the top
of the maneuver was incorrect and he
should have then easily been able to fly
an escape maneuver and then carry on
with this display or stop altogether
looking for the right height for an
experienced pilots a loupe is a
relatively straightforward maneuver but
they're also trained on how to get out
of trouble if something goes wrong we
asked mark to demonstrate what happens
if you haven't gained sufficient height
or speed the escape maneuver is called
unloading and rolling out safely in a
different direction
Vande Hill failed to do this compound in
his original error at the beginning of
his loop Mark Petrie says Shoreham can
be a tricky airfield to display over
because the runway dual-carriageway
coastline and river are in close
proximity but under normal circumstances
a pilot should be able to adapt to an
altitude error you have sufficient time
if you are fully conscious and aware of
what's going on around you
and it's part of the process of doing
aerobatic maneuvers especially in a high
powered aeroplane that you should be
checking at specific points that you've
met the gate requirements and then be
ready to respond to it if when you look
at it the numbers are wrong the
prosecution had argued that mr. Hill had
made other errors at air shows included
at this display in Southport in 2014 the
organizer issued an emergency
stopstopstop call because he felt mr.
Hill had flown too close to spectators
he admitted the mistake but his friends
defended his record I've never known him
take any risks he amongst many others
including myself will have made small
errors during the course of our flying
careers but he was a very disciplined a
very focused individual took a great
deal of interest in the detail of every
sortie when he gave evidence in his own
defense he talked about the tragedy
tried to explain his actions but didn't
apologize to families of those who died
who were in
court we all felt that andrew hill has
to take responsibility for what had
happened they were well very lengthy
pieces of video footage that we sat
through and it was almost like a master
class in this is andrew hill and how he
actually flies and perhaps his lawyers
had told him not to say anything about
any sort of remorse but it just seemed
that it was almost like he was lecturing
us rather than taking as I said
responsibility for it but an hour after
he was found not guilty mr. Hill emerged
from court to deliver the apology the
families had waited so long to hear 1290
five days ago I lost control of an
aircraft resulting in the death of
Morris Abraham's Dylan Archer
Tony bright well James Mallinson Matthew
Grimstone Matt Jones Danny any poly tube
pollito mark Reeth Jacob Schultz Richard
Smith mark Trotter a number of people
were injured I'm truly sorry for the
part I played in their death today that
I will remember for the rest of my life
understandably the Shoreham disaster had
a profound impact on air displays
hundreds of thousands of spectators
flocked to see air shows in Britain and
Ireland but the Civil Aviation Authority
tightened the rules to stop fast jets
performing over populated areas hawker
hunters are still banned from any
aerobatics if that means that people no
longer feel comfortable displaying to
their personal limit if that would norm
at normally include loops barrel rolls
and other
Hayate what we consider to be
high-energy maneuvers I think that would
be a shame for the public because part
of the spectacle is to display these
aircraft in the context of what they
were designed for and if all of a sudden
we only feel inclined for personal risk
and other reasons to fry them straight
past the crowd straight and level
I think the nations lost something but
it might be safer it's safe to leave
them on the ground
despite the disaster of those in charge
of British air shows want to see the
Hawker hunter flying again put yourself
in the shoes of a family who've lost
somebody to this accident how would you
feel if you were looking in the skies
and saw another Hawker hunter doing a
aleut maneuver in front of you it would
be extremely difficult and I'm sure a
very emotional experience but and indeed
of course it is intrinsically personal
but one would hope that they would never
ever ever see an incident like that
again organisers of air shows have
argued that mr. hills crash was an
isolated tragic mistake they were the
first public fatalities at an air
display since 31 died at the Farnborough
airshow in 1952 but that's of little
comfort to the families of the men who
died in such a horrific way Andy hill
may have no memory of the crash but the
bereaved relatives will never forget his
catastrophic error